[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian Sievers
guten Abend in allen keine gute
Leistungsbilanz Auftrag nicht genug
erfüllt Vertrauen angeknackst es ist ein
ziemlich düsteres Zeugnis dass da der
Berliner Regierungskoalition ausgestellt
wird
interessanterweise von einem der selbst
Teil davon ist Vizekanzler Robert Habeck
hat sich bei den Kolleginnen und
Kollegen der ARD bitter beschwert über
das Klima und den Arbeitsfortschritt
innerhalb der Ampel
jetzt muss man davon ausgehen dass wir
damit auch ein Zeichen an seine eigene
Partei setzen will man die Grünen den er
im vergangenen Jahr zu sehr Bittsteller
beim Emir und zu wenig Klimaschützer war
und dennoch bleibt für die Menschen in
diesem Land die Frage was ist von einer
Regierung zu halten die sich selbst
offenbar nicht mehr besonders gut findet
Daniel Franzen
heute Nachmittag sein Puls so scheint es
hat sich wieder gesehen nachdem er
gestern neuerlichen Einblick gewährt
hatte in Seelen Leben jener Koalition
die für sich den Namen
fortschrittskoalition erfand es ging
gestern unter anderem um den
Gesetzentwurf zum heizungsaustausch
hier ist der Gesetzentwurf an die
Bild-Zeitung und ich muss also
unterstellen bewusst gelegt worden um
dem Vertrauen in der Regierung zu
schaden und
eine Regierung die das Vertrauen
verspielt hat natürlich ihr größtes Fund
verloren erstaunlich war für viele die
Schärfe bewusste Vertrauensbruch viel
mehr Vorwurf geht nicht an wen er
adressiert war Lisa Beck offen auch
heute das weiß ich nicht denn es ist ja
ein großes Geheimnis woher die
Journalisten ihre Quellen haben so trat
er im Regierungsviertel ein munteres
ratespiellos wo nun die undichte Stelle
lag falls es sie gab bei FDP SPD oder
doch gar den Grünen selbst
Geständnisse gab es keine natürlich aber
Reaktionen die ebenfalls etwas aussagten
über die Atmosphäre in der Ampel
inhaltlich wie auch zwischen den Zeilen
ich weiß nicht wie dieser Gesetzentwurf
von die Öffentlichkeit gekommen ist ist
aber auch nicht das erste Mal dass das
aus grünen Ministerien passiert ich habe
jetzt gemerkt der Wirtschaftsminister
hat dann scheint in seiner eigenen
Partei ein bisschen Druck im Moment auf
dem Kessel die Themen sind auch groß die
im Moment auf dem Tisch liegen aber ich
glaube man sollte mit dem Druck nicht so
umgehen dass man jetzt einfach in alle
Richtungen deswegen Koffer hat bei den
Grünen gibt es nicht wenige die in der
Kanzlerpartei längst den subtileren
koalitionsintern Rivalen sehen damit sie
die Grünen nicht nächste Kanzlerpartei
werden es ist diese taktische Ebene die
auch schon ihr Verhältnis beschwerte und
das in Zeiten so viele ungelöste Fragen
eben zum Beispiel ob das geplante
heizungsgesetz nun kommt zum neuen Jahr
oder nicht wir haben natürlich alle
möglichen Konstellationen mit Gas
Etagenheizung mit unterschiedlichen
Besitzern mit allen möglichen
technischen Einschränkungen aufgrund des
Denkmalschutzes deswegen im Grunde sind
wir uns einig aber im Detail stecken
noch natürlich noch sehr viel Arbeit und
das nicht nur hier die meisten noch
offenen Fragen kreisen um das große Loch
zwischen Anspruch und Wirklichkeit beim
Thema Klimaschutz am Sonntag ist
Koalitionsausschuss und schon jetzt gibt
es einen Ampel Appell an sich selbst
dass die Energie die in diese diesen
Streit gerade einfließen besser dafür
genutzt werden sollten um inhaltlich und
konzeptionell zu arbeiten bislang
nämlich in der Tat scheinen erneuerbar
vor allem jene Energien innerhalb der
Ampel die gegeneinander gerichtet sind
ganz unabhängig von Sonne Wind und
Wetter
besonders im Visier des
Wirtschaftsministers und von dessen
Grünen ist der FDP Verkehrsminister
Volker Wissing schönen guten Abend
guten Abend was sollen wir denn von
einer Regierung halten die ich zitiere
den Vizekanzler Gesetzentwürfe liegt
Gespräche absichtlich zerstört des
billigen taktischen Vorteils wegen
also ich halte von solchen Dingen nichts
beteilige mich auch nicht daran die
Zeiten sind Ernst wir müssen seriös
regieren wir haben enormen Aufholbedarf
in Deutschland die Dinge sind sehr lange
liegen geblieben das Land braucht
Fortschritt und daran arbeite ich seriös
regieren gucken wir mal auf den
konkreten Fall der jetzt gerade
Diskussion ist ab 2024 soll es in neuen
Gebäuden keine Öl- und Gasheizungen mehr
geben diesen Zeitplan hatte die
Koalition vor einem Jahr beschlossen
auch die FDP bei Bekannt werden eines
ersten Gesetzentwurfs erklärte die FDP
dann aber sie trage das Vorhaben nicht
mehr mit ist das gute Zusammenarbeit und
seriöses regieren
eine Regierung muss die Sorgen der
Bevölkerung sehr ernst nehmen Menschen
machen sich Sorgen dass sie überfordert
werden können durch den
Transformationsprozess Menschen wollen
nicht durch immer neue Verbote
eingeschränkt werden und deswegen müssen
wir diese Dinge innerhalb der Regierung
besprechen und klären wir haben immer
gesagt dass wir nichts davon halten ein
Verbot ans andere zu rein weil wir
müssen die Gesellschaft mitnehmen der
der Bevölkerung
Verbote es geht darum dass das in neuen
Gebäuden keine Öl und Gasheizungen mehr
eingebaut werden sollen selbst ihr
Fraktionschef Christian dürr hat heute
gesagt ihm liege gar kein Entwurf zum
Verbot vor warum sprechen sie von
verboten
dann entscheidend ist dass wir
Klimaschutz so betreiben dass wir die
Menschen mitnehmen niemand darf
überfordert werden Bauen Wohnen heizen
muss auch bezahlbar bleiben und diese
Dinge müssen wir in der Regierung
besprechen und wenn wir uns dann auf
einen Gesetzentwurf verständigt haben
dann stehen wir auch dahinter aber es
muss natürlich möglich sein dass auch
innerhalb einer Regierung
unterschiedliche politische Positionen
artikuliert werden wir brauchen das
Ringen um die beste Lösung und nicht das
unterordnen bessere Ideen was jetzt ganz
dringend tatsächlich in Brüssel von der
EU erwartet wird nämlich eine Aussage
von Ihnen Herr witzig da war eigentlich
um das kurz zu erklären eigentlich
beschlossen dass in der EU ab 2035 keine
Autos mit Verbrenner mehr zugelassen
werden dürfen das haben sie dann
überraschend blockiert jetzt wundert
sich ein Großteil der EU über das
deutsche Vorgehen auf der anderen Seite
gibt es Länder wie Italien das jetzt
drauf sattelt und weitere Ausnahmen
möchte am Ende so ist die Befürchtung
fliegt die gesamte Gesetzgebung zum
verbrenn ermotor auseinander ist das was
sie wollen
nein auf keinen Fall ich möchte dass wir
Klimaschutz betreiben dass wir uns zwar
Klimaschutz betreiben mit allen
Möglichkeiten alle technologischen
Lösungen sollen einen Beitrag leisten
können um klimaneutral mobil zu sein und
unsere Logistikketten auch klimaneutral
zu organisieren und deswegen kämpfe ich
nicht gegen diese Regulierung sondern
ich kämpfe dafür dass sie verbessert
wird diese Regulierung hat einen Manko
und nämlich es fehlt das Element der
technologieoffenheit und das soll jetzt
noch ergänzt werden dafür setze ich mich
ein aber übrigens
vergangenen Jahr schon deutlich gemacht
dafür hat die EU-Kommission einen
Kompromissvorschlag gemacht der liegt
auf dem Tisch sie wollten den prüfen sie
haben Sie sich denn entschieden
also es ist nicht so dass nur die
EU-Kommission Vorschläge gemacht hat
sondern wir haben auch welche gemacht
und die wir haben es handelt sich ja
schon mal sehr kompliziertes auch
europarechtlich sehr kompliziertes
Verfahren und deswegen haben wir
vereinbart dass die Dinge jetzt auch
sehr genau geprüft werden wir waren
etwas unglücklich darüber dass die
EU-Kommission nicht früher Vorschläge
auf den Tisch gelegt hat weil wir das
erwartet hatten auch nach den Gesprächen
die wir im letzten Jahr geführt haben
aber wir müssen jetzt nach vorne schauen
wir brauchen eine Lösung und die wird
jetzt die Zeit läuft ab morgen ein
bisschen ist EU-Gipfel in Brüssel die
Zeit läuft ab die die Europäer sagen sie
brauchen eigentlich eine Einigung bis
Freitag das ist nicht mehr weit hin bis
dahin bis dahin dann grünes Licht auch
von Volker Wissing zu erwarten oder
riskieren Sie das quasi die gesamte
Klimaschutz das gesamte Klimaschutzpaket
der Europäischen Union am Ende kippt
also mit Verlaub wir reden um
eine Regulierung die für das Jahr
2035 und sagt wie es dann weitergeht und
jetzt will man hier bitte nicht erklären
dass es jetzt auf einen Tag ankommt ich
möchte aber auch nichts verzögern ich
möchte sorgfältig prüfen und das ist
auch im Interesse der Bundesrepublik
Deutschland dass diese Fragen sorgfältig
geklärt werden und ich möchte das
verbindlich vereinbart wird dass wir
eine
technologieoffene Regulierung bekommen
und nicht die Konzentration auf nur ein
Mobilitätsangebot wie können wir denn
annehmen dass weniger mehr sein kann das
halte ich für ein Irrtum und deswegen
ist es uns sehr wichtig das haben wir im
vergangenen Jahr schon adressiert und
deswegen ist es für niemanden
überraschend dass wir jetzt genau das
gleiche einfordern was wir im letzten
Jahr schon eingefordert haben und jetzt
brauchen wir die notwendige Sorgfalt ich
bin bereit diese Fragen schnell zu
klären ich bin aber nicht bereit
Vereinbarungen zu unterzeichnen deren
Stück weiter und Inhalt ich nicht
abschließend für die Bundesrepublik
Deutschland geprüft habe wir sind aber
in den letzten Tagen sehr weit gekommen
sind verhandlungsfähig und ich bin
optimistisch dass wenn die EU-Kommission
unser Anliegen umsetzt und bereit ist
das aufzugreifen dass wir dann auch zu
einem Ergebnis kommen wir haben klare
Vorstellungen unterbrechen
Automobilindustrie selbst die
Lobbyverbände der Autobranche sagen wir
wollen eigentlich gar nicht diese
technologieoffenheit die sie hier
ansprechen wir setzen voll auf
E-Mobilität auf die Stroma das andere
was Sie wollen nämlich e-fuels das wäre
höchstens ein ein kleinserienmarkt
sozusagen kann man also annehmen dass es
ihnen am Ende darum geht gar nicht so
sehr um dieses Detail sondern am Ende
darum geht das gesamte aus für den
Verbrenner zu blockieren und zu stoppen
europaweit
also zunächst einmal ich bin
verantwortlich dafür dass diese
Gesellschaft mobil bleibt das auch die
Bedürfnisse der Menschen
ernst genommen werden auch in der Fläche
ein individuelles Mobilitätsangebot zu
haben und da sehe ich die große Chance
in der technologieoffenheit in der
Vielfalt der Antriebsarten die natürlich
klimaneutral sein müssen und nicht in
der Konzentration auf nur ein Angebot
meine Sorge ist nicht die welche Gewinne
macht die Industrie damit so meine Sorge
ist die was bedeutet denn diese
Regulierung für die Beschäftigten und
vor allen Dingen für die Bürgerinnen und
Bürger die ein bezahlbares
Mobilitätsangebot brauchen und zwar
nicht nur im nächsten jahrzehn auch im
übernächsten Jahrzehnt und lassen sie
mich zum Verbrenner etwas betonen die
die Technologie des Verbrennungsmotors
beherrschen wir in Deutschland besser
als der Rest der Welt und es ist
sinnvoll wenn nicht alle Fragen der
klimaneutralen Mobilität beantwortet
sind diese Technologie weiter in der
Hand zu behalten was bringt es denn für
einen Mehrwert wenn wir sie jetzt
verbieten es ist doch niemandem geholfen
wenn eine Technologie verboten wird die
uns klimaneutrale mobilitäts Chancen in
der Zukunft und auch heute schon
ermöglicht Gottes klingt nicht so als ob
sich die FDP da jetzt in den nächsten
Tagen mit Europa einigen wird Volker
Wissing der Bundesverkehrsminister ich
danke Ihnen ganz herzlich für das
Gespräch heute Abend
ich danke auch ihnen und bleibe
weiterhin optimistisch dass wir eine
Einigung schaffen werden
wir werden uns sehen das Gespräch haben
wir vor 90 Minuten aus Termin Gründen
aufgezeichnet es knirscht ja nicht nur
bei wärmewende und Verkehrswende auch
bei der Energiewende liegen die
angestrebten Ziele und der tatsächliche
stand weit auseinander im Jahr 2030 soll
nach den Plänen der Bundesregierung
mindestens 80% des Stroms aus
erneuerbaren Energien kommen wie Wind
und Sonne derzeit ist es etwa die Hälfte
auch hier kommt wieder klimaminister
Harbeck ins Spiel der bereits einen
Turbo eingeschaltet hat nur dass der
bislang nicht wirklich zündet Habeck
versucht heute einen neuen Turbo und
lädt zum Windkraft Gipfel Eva Schiller
mit mehr dazu
wenn im Norden viel Wind weht könnte man
meinen ein guter Tag für Umwelt und
Stromkunden ist aber nicht so denn im
Süden mit viel weniger Windrädern müssen
sie Strom jetzt teuer zukaufen um das
Netz stabil zu halten wir bekommen einen
seltenen Einblick in eine der großen
Schaltzentralen jeden Tag bügeln Sie das
Nord-Süd-Gefälle aus weil Leitungen
fehlen dann führt das ja dazu dass wir
höhere Kosten haben und es führt dazu
dass man mehr CO2 imitiert weil wir ja
praktisch dort
konventionell Kraftwerke meistens
Kohlekraftwerke eben extra anfahren
müssen ein Dilemma das schon lange Wert
und schwer schnell zu ändern ist also
demonstriert Energieminister Habeck
zumindest Tatendrang gestern Sparten
Stich für den Netzausbau heute
windgipfel
wir sehen doch nicht die
genehmigungsgeschwindigkeit die
notwendig ist mehr Flächen zur Verfügung
zu stellen schnellere
Genehmigungsverfahren zu machen ist
dadurch eine Aufgabe geworden eine
gesamtgesellschaftliche Aufgabe geworden
und der Geist mit dem wir hier mit den
ressortkolleginnen und Kollegen
zusammengearbeitet haben spiegelt genau
das wieder dann fünf neue Windräder pro
Tag das Ziel der Regierung fünf
Windkraftanlagen im Jahr waren es 2022
in Baden-Württemberg oft läuft es wie
hier in bretzingen eine Bürgerinitiative
wehrt sich seit über 8 Jahren gegen den
geplanten Windpark der Bürgermeister hat
nichts gegen Windräder aber ihn nervt
das Diktat aus Berlin erfordert
Mitbestimmung und eine Energiestrategie
wir brechen jetzt bei den Windrädern vor
haben aber vergessen den Netzausbau und
dann auch gespeicher Lösungen in der
gleichen Intensität voranzutreiben da
haben wir noch eine große Lücke und ich
sehe schon dass wir Windparks bauen
Windräder da stehen haben die sich da
nicht drehen werden
von 14.000 km neuen Netzen sind gerade
mal 1900 Leitungen im Betrieb
1500 genehmigt oder im Bau einige der
Kilometer hätten wir uns schon längst am
Netz gewünscht einige wären auch schon
vor ein paar Jahren dran gewesen es
nützt aber jetzt nichts nach hinten zu
schauen es sind Fehler gemacht worden
für die Fehler werden wir jetzt bezahlen
und so kaufen Sie in den Schaltzentralen
im Süden weiter schmutzigen Strom zu
obwohl es im Norden genug grünen Strom
gäbe und sie machen sich hier keine
Illusionen bis der Ausbau der Netze und
der Ausbau der Windkraft im
Gleichgewicht stehen werden noch viele
Jahre vergehen
ambitionierte Ziele so sagen manche das
ist die Umschreibung für fast unmöglich
andererseits wusste schon Lessing der
Langsamste der sein Ziel nicht aus den
Augen verliert geht immer noch
geschwinder als jener der ohne Ziel
umherirrt
Hannah du hast jetzt die
Nachrichtenübersicht an diesem Mittwoch
ja und da blicken wir zuerst auf eine
erneute großer Erzieher in der
reichsbürgersszene in mehreren
Bundesländern bei der in
Baden-Württemberg ein Beamter
angeschossen und verletzt wurde der
Schütze sitzt in Untersuchungshaft gegen
ihn wird nun wegen mehrfachen versuchten
Mordes ermittelt nach Angaben der
Bundesanwaltschaft gibt es fünf weitere
Beschuldigte denen die Unterstützung
einer terroristischen Vereinigung
vorgeworfen wird darunter laut
Medienberichten ein Polizist und ein
Angehöriger der Bundeswehr bereits im
Dezember waren bei Razzien mehrere
Personen aus dem Milieu festgenommen
worden die einen Sturz der Regierung
geplant haben sollen
zu Lage in der Ukraine dort sind bei
russischen Luftangriffen in
verschiedenen Teilen des Landes laut
Behörden mindestens 14 Menschen getötet
worden nach einem drohenden Angriff auf
zivile Ziele Naht hier werden in den
Trümmern noch verschüttete vermutet in
saporicia im Süden des Landes trafen
Raketen Wohngebäude Präsident selenski
erte Soldaten in der Nähe der schwer
umkämpften Stadt bachmut auch dort gab
es nach ukrainischen Angaben wieder Tote
und Verletzte
nach der Verabschiedung der umstrittenen
Rentenreform in Frankreich hat Präsident
macron das Vorhaben in einem
Fernsehinterview verteilt die Reform sei
kein Luxus sondern eine Notwendigkeit
die Bevölkerung davon nicht überzeugt zu
haben bedauere er
Oppositionspolitiker warfen ihm
anschließend vor arrogant zu sein und
nicht zuzuhören auch morgen soll es
wieder landesweit Proteste und Streiks
geben
nach dem tödlichen Angriff auf einen
Transmann auf dem Christopher Street Day
in Münster im vergangenen Sommer ist der
Angreifer zu einer Jugendstrafe von fünf
Jahren verurteilt worden das Landgericht
Münster sprach den 20-Jährigen wegen
Körperverletzung mit Todesfolge schuldig
und ordnete die Unterbringung in einer
Erziehungsanstalt für Suchtkranke
Straftäter an der Angeklagte hatte im
vergangenen August zunächst mehrere
Teilnehmer der Parade beschimpft und
dann den 25-Jährigen Transmann
niedergeschlagen im Krankenhaus verstarb
das Opfer
eine Stunde wir nehmen es als
selbstverständlich wenn wir den Mund
unter den Wasserhahn halten und sauberes
Wasser ist tatsächlich ein Menschenrecht
aber jeder vierte Mensch auf dieser Welt
hat kein sauberes Wasser die Vereinten
Nationen beraten seit heute auf einer
großen wasserkonferenz in New York die
letzte ist bereits 46 Jahre her dass die
Erde zu zwei Dritteln mit Wasser bedeckt
ist hilft wenig denn nahezu alles Wasser
ist Salzwasser in den riesigen Ozean nur
ein winziger Teil nämlich drei Prozent
ist tatsächlich Süßwasser und das lagert
hauptsächlich als Eis an Polkappen und
in Gletschern bleibt auf der Welt nur
knapp ein Prozent als mögliches
Trinkwasser übrig die gute Nachricht
selbst ein Prozent wäre immer noch mehr
als genug für uns alle doch es ist eben
sehr ungleich verteilt einige Regionen
vor allem in Afrika haben viel zu wenig
Wasser oft kommen Naturkatastrophen wie
Überschwemmungen dazu die auch die
sauberen Wasserquellen treffen wie in
Malawi wo verunreinigt das Wasser gerade
zu einem verheerenden Ausbruch der
Cholera führt Barbara Völkel und
Christine Elsner berichten
sie sind krank weil sie keinen Zugang zu
sauberem Wasser haben die Menschen im
ostafrikanischen Malawi das Land erlebt
den tödlichsten Cholera Ausbruch in
seiner Geschichte die Zahlen sind
erschreckend
wir haben über 55
000 Fälle davon über 13.000 Kinder wir
haben 1700 Todesfälle keine sanitären
Einrichtungen keine Kanalisation so
leben die Menschen im Abwasser
zusätzlich wird das Wasser durch
Unmengen von Müll verschmutzt die Kinder
sie haben keine Alternative Trinken aus
der Brühe spielen darin die Folge
lebensbedrohende Krankheiten
eine aktuelle Studie von UNICEF belegt
weltweit sterben täglich mehr als 1.000
Kinder durch verschmutztes Wasser
Klimawandel und Kriege verschärfen den
Kampf um sauberes Wasser allein in
Afrika sind 190 Millionen Kinder von der
Wasserkrise betroffen viele humanitäre
Organisationen beobachten eine
Zuspitzung der wasserkatastrophe das
Ergebnis alarmierend wir sehen jetzt
bereits dass es in einigen Regionen in
denen Wasser knapp ist zum Beispiel am
Horn von Afrika Konflikte zunehmen
aufgrund des knappen Wassers Familien
sehen sich gezwungen ihre Heimat zu
verlassen weil sie nicht genügend
Trinkwasser haben oder keine
Weideflächen für ihre Tiere finden was
leider zunimmt das Wasser immer mehr als
Waffe eingesetzt wird das heißt es
werden gezielt Wasserstellen verschmutzt
somit zählen weite Teile Afrikas zu den
Regionen mit der größten Wasser
Unsicherheit der Welt
was wir im Norden als selbstverständlich
erachten ist in malawien kostbares Gut
es gibt entweder zu wenig sauberes
Wasser oder eben auch zu viel unser
oberes Wasser und das ist häufig
belastet mit giftigen Substanzen keinen
regelmäßigen Zugang zu sauberem Wasser
haben ein Viertel der Weltbevölkerung
also rund 2 Milliarden Menschen daher
die Forderung an die weltwasserkonferenz
die weltwasserkonferenz in New York ist
eine einmalige Gelegenheit und wir
müssen diese Gelegenheit nutzen denn bis
zum Jahr 2030 sollen alle Menschen
weltweit Zugang zu Trinkwasser und zu
sanitären Anlagen haben davon sind wir
gerade noch sehr weit entfernt das heißt
was wir jetzt brauchen ist eine neue
globale Agenda für Wasser für Abwasser
dazu gehören zum Beispiel neue Brunnen
dazu gehören tausende zehntausende
lateinen und neue Abwassersysteme große
Anstrengungen doch um diese Ziele zu
erreichen so Experten braucht es weitaus
mehr Anstrengungen
die US-Notenbank Fett hat den Leitzins
ein weiteres Mal angehoben um 0,25%
Punkte eine Entscheidung die mit
Spannung erwartet wurde denn die Fett
steckt in einer Zwickmühle Valerie
Haller warum genau und wie ist jetzt
dieser Zinsschritt einzuordnen ja also
die Fett steckt in einer Zwickmühle weil
sie einerseits die Inflation bekämpfen
und dafür die Zinsen anheben muss
andererseits sind die höheren Zinsen
eine Belastung für Banken die Fett hat
sich aber für die Zinserhöhung
entschieden und sagt damit eigentlich
zweierlei der Kampf gegen die Inflation
muss sein und das Bankensystem ist
stabil also stabil genug um die Zinsen
wenigstens ein bisschen anzuheben
insofern ist dieser Zinsschritt heute
auch als Signal des Vertrauens an die
Finanzmärkte zu verstehen aber anders
als sonst bleibt die amerikanische
Notenbank über weitere Zinsschritte vage
da hält sie sich also alles offen also
ganz so sicher ist sich die Fett ihrer
Sache nicht die Turbulenzen bei den
Banken sind noch nicht verdaut
ja und eine weitere wichtige Meldung
heute die Konjunkturprognose der
Wirtschaftsweisen genau die
Wirtschaftsweisen sagen wir sind noch
nicht über dem Berg die Energiekrise
könnte uns im kommenden Winter wieder
einholen aber immerhin eine Rezession
ist für sie vom Tisch die Inflation
allerdings bleibt ihrer Ansicht nach
weiter hoch Entspannung erst 2024 ja im
laufenden Jahr warten die
Sachverständigen ein Mini-Wachstum von
0,2% im kommenden Jahr
1,3%. damit asttestieren sie Deutschland
wenig Schwung eine Finanzkrise aber
sehen die Experten nicht aufziehen in
mahnen jedoch die Banken Aufsichten
seien nicht effizient genug müssen
schneller auf Probleme reagieren und
häufiger mit stresste überwachen vielen
Dank Valerie für diese Einschätzungen
in mehreren Bundesländern hat es wieder
Warnstreiks im öffentlichen Dienst
gegeben in Hamburg wurde der Hafen für
große Schiffe gesperrt in vielen Städten
der Verkehr lahmgelegt an den
Kundgebungen beteiligten sich 10000
Beschäftigte auch morgen soll gestreikt
werden noch liegen die Positionen von
Arbeitgebern und Gewerkschaften weit
auseinander am Montag startet die
nächste Verhandlungsrunde
zu den Lottozahlen an diesem Mittwoch
die lauten 19 28 33 35 38 40 Superzahl 3
alle Angaben wie immer ohne Gewähr
wollten Sie immer schon mal wissen wie
Schauspieler arbeiten sich in ihre
Rollen hineinversetzen hinein leben für
einen Theaterabend oder für einen Film
jemand anderes werden
einer der allerbesten den wir hier haben
in Deutschland nimmt uns jetzt mit lässt
uns ganz nah ran nicht an den Privatmann
Lars Eidinger sondern an den Preis
gekrönten Profi ein Jahr lang waren die
Kameras dabei das stört Eidinger nicht
im Gegenteil entstanden ist nicht nur
ein Film über einen Schauspieler sondern
über das Schauspielen an sich findet
Claudio Armbruster wenn ich sowas Spiele
dann will ich das hier absolute Ruhe ist
oder nicht sein wenn Lars Eidinger
spielt wird es nicht langweilig er macht
sich nackt körperlich und emotional
das Eidinger will gesehen werden
unbedingt
Erfüllung auf die man leidenschaftlich
kaufen könnte
sterben das ist nicht Eitelkeit sondern
tiefes Schauspieler Bedürfnis ein
Interview mit uns vor ein paar Tagen das
wird genau Schnittbilder ich habe halt
das Gefühl wenn ich nicht gesehen werde
wenn ich keinen gegenüber habe an dem
ich mich orientieren kann dann fühle ich
mich seltsam verloren ja das begreift
mich nur durch das Gegenüber und es gibt
eine Szene in dem Film die eigentlich ja
im Grunde die zentrale Szene ist wo ich
mit dem Regisseur aneinander geraten
weil er sich aus dieser Verbindung
rausziehen
bei den Proben zum jedermann in Salzburg
was macht ihr denn jetzt ist ein
komischer Moment was macht ihr jetzt
warum gehst du jetzt rüber
natürlich respektiere was organisieren
muss kannst du es nicht verstehen
so aber es beschreibt mich halt trotzdem
auch in meiner Widersprüchlichkeit oder
Fehlerhaftigkeit
egal welche Rolle er spielt
Musik
Hamlet Richard III oder was auch immer
es kann passieren dass er ausbricht
aus dem Text aus dem Stück
dass er die Grenzen überschreitet
Wand ja wo man sagt es gibt eine
Trennung zwischen
[Musik]
Zuschauer Zuschauerinnen und
Schauspielerin
und die versuche ich zu durchbrechen
einfach um die um den großen Trumpf des
Theaters auszuspielen die
Unmittelbarkeit und ich glaube deswegen
wird es Theater auch immer geben weil
damit kann kein anderes Medium
konkurrieren und das ist auch was was
die Leute fasziniert
[Musik]
Lars Eidinger ist ein Glücksfall für die
Schauspielkunst
und dieser Film ist ein Glücksfall für
die die sich für diese Kunst
interessieren
Lars Eidinger ist unfassbar eitel und
unglaublich unterhaltsam schreibt die
Filmkritik und großartig offen alles zu
sehen ab morgen im Kino
ja und hier zu sehen gegen 0.30 unser
heute journal Update mit Nazan gökdemir
und jetzt gleich nach uns das
auslandsjournal und von uns allen hier
Danke für heute und gerne bis morgen
tschüss
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter unsere
regensummenkarte zeigt die Summe des
Regens bis sonntags sehen es hier wie
sich das Blau intensiviert vor allem den
westlichen Mittelgebirgen bis zu 40
Liter auf den Quadratmeter die dann
runterkommen werden nach Osten ist es
deutlich weniger und was wir noch sehen
auf der Alpen Südseite Richtung
Norditalien kaum nennenswerter
Niederschlag hier setzt sich die Dürre
fort schauen auf die Nacht und der Regen
kommt von Südwesten auf verlagert sich
nach Nordosten dort erstmal trocken oder
auch im Süden Temperatur Rückgang dabei
auf drei Grad an den Alpen und 11 Grad
ganz im Westen Deutschland z.B am
Niederrhein morgen dann am Vormittag im
Norden viele Wolken und Regen dazu
Sturmböen ja am Süden lässt dann der
Regen allmählich nach die Sonne kommt
schon häufiger hervor zum Nachmittag ist
es dort trocken aber nach Norden den
Schauer Gewitter die können auch mal
kräftiger ausfallen Temperaturen dazu
höchste Werte mit 21 Grad in Oberbayern
17 Grad nach Osten hin und 11 Grad in
Schleswig-Holstein dort wird es am
kühlsten sein ja und die nächsten Tage
weitere Schauer und Gewitter am Freitag
dazu Sturm vor allem Richtung Nordsee
Temperaturen 10 bis 18 Grad am Samstag
fast überall im Land im Tagesverlauf mal
Sturmböen da Zuschauer und Gewitter 8
bis 14 Grad und der Sonntag wird spürbar
Kühler damit ein schöner Abend